[Music]
anybody ever uh run away from the cops
before yeah i knew you [ __ ] would say
that what what happened graffiti for me
you used to make it did you get away
yeah oh one time no oh [ __ ] what was
your bomb i wasn't running huh what was
your bombing style were you doing late
at night were you putting your name down
getting your names or whatever see you
got photos
i'll show you it's pretty interesting
[ __ ] yeah honestly i want to go bombing
i've never done it right now in general
no at night time or something like that
what's bombing i'm not cool enough for
this graffiti okay i've never done
graffiti before i think i'd be really
bad at it i think it was my first like
love for like something where i obsessed
over it it was like a passion of mine
like i did it all the time
yeah and then like the funnest thing
though is like going out and doing it
and then like you don't know if you're
gonna get
like well for one you don't want to get
caught with gangs because they'll [ __ ]
you up and then you don't you know just
like territorially gangs don't want
graffiti in their neighborhood they'll
they'll like [ __ ] you up so like
but it's just that's the whole rush of
all of it you know what's your tiger
name kami for kamikaze
okay am i yeah
cool so if you see that please arrest us
man
right now thank you
possible fictional story there's a bunch
of on the 110 that just says aids aids
yeah like under the freeway passage i
don't know what that i don't know whose
tag her name that is but
it's just aids magic johnson i saw one
yesterday i saw one on an overpass that
said let's go brandon
huge friends of baby
that's sick that's like graffiti but
like very positive it was really
positive yeah i was like all right let's
go brandon somebody else over here say
they ran away from college he said he
said he did
no nevermind was it because when you
were stealing that one time yeah from
target yeah
no no i never i've always you know it
was like
i think we ran away from costco in high
school like running from a party well
that was it nothing crazy
we're not that cool yeah irresponsible
were you guys successful in the running
away but when i got caught i was
painting up like a that's not successful
but yeah yeah i didn't run from them
because they they ambushed us
so basically uh me and my friends were
painting at a train yard and then at a
train yard they have the security guys
because most guys paint there so then
when they came we just hopped the fence
and instead of leaving
our dumbasses went there's another wall
here let's go for it so we're painting
right oh [ __ ]
broad daylight because
we don't
yeah we just [ __ ] did it all day all
like whenever
and then there's some people playing
basketball i think they called the cops
and then by the time we left it was it
was like a junior high with the park
connected and all this stuff and we went
out and as we walked out the gate
motorcycle cop comes three cop cars they
all just surround us and i was like how
old are you 14. guns drawn yeah nah we
shouldn't break they grabbed us up
though
but we were we were they're like loud
and [ __ ] and yelling at us and we're
like [ __ ] but it was like a 12 year old
13 14 17 and one of our buddies just
turned 18.
he's [ __ ] yeah so when they took us to
the station
they're like oh you're 18. and then all
the cops clapped and then they said
you're going inside oh and you started
[ __ ] crying
and i was i was like i was locked up on
the bench like [ __ ]
man these guys are these guys enjoy
[ __ ] locust enough man like i was
like i don't know i don't that was my
first real experience with like cops
like that you know before that it's just
you know it's like sit on the [ __ ]
curb you know what gang you from
whatever but before that i never been to
the station like that so i was like just
trying to be a tough guy but at the same
time sitting down like [ __ ] am i gonna
go into jail where am i gonna go i don't
know i don't know and then one by one
like they call up like our parents are
coming to pick us up and you see the
different ways of how
parents treat their kids
like some parents are just kind of like
quiet and they're just like all right
come on let's go home like oh that that
kid's parents loves them
some of them will be just like
yelling at everybody the cops the kids
everyone this is one one kid his mom
just started [ __ ] wailing on him in
the station yeah cops are like sounds
like an asian mom
samoan
samoan yeah yeah [ __ ] samoan pants those
hits hurt yeah
it was crazy man hands like you know
like catcher's mess dude
[ __ ] maui the demi god dude yeah my
my buddy um his name is rinaldi he was
he was the 18 year old one and after
that i never i haven't seen him like
yeah yeah until like that was the last
time you saw him yeah [ __ ] killed him
i think his mom did kill him though we
always say that last time i haven't seen
him in like
maybe 10 years right i was working at
this restaurant
and um he was sitting at the bar one day
and he looked over he was like
commie
and i'm like what the [ __ ] and i'm like
oh [ __ ] dude what's up yeah that's your
gang name i'm calling tommy from now on
actually that's so sick i'm gonna call
him kaze
you're such a not communist that's
really funny
yeah yeah it's the most capitalist guy i
also thought communist but i'm glad you
said kamikaze yeah
but kami's like you know hello because
when you in in in graffiti when you go
out and do it's called bombing right so
kamikaze pilot that does make a little
bit of sense yeah
let's go brandon so there's a there's
dude his uh name is thomas right
that tank engine he's a 44 year old dude
he uh
police get a 911 call on wednesday about
a dispute inside of a building in new
york
uh and this dude rudy thomas thomas's
last name actually is the person who is
actually wanted in connection with a
past assault they didn't specify the
nature of it but uh when this guy
started running away he ran
and then he climbed into and on top of a
tree nice wow to run away from the cops
very very tall tree nice close to his
house
um and this guy's a leopard he stayed in
this tree and police were trying to talk
him out of coming down the street
he stayed there for 48 hours
that's a lot he didn't pee or poop or
nothing huh well here's the thing though
neighbors say that during dark hours and
crazy times he actually snuck a few
times into the his window of his own
spot
that was like where the height of his
tree was but then he came back out and
came back out wait that wasn't his that
was his home that means he's got them
right where he wants them
why does he just go inside the house to
stay there barricade it smells crazy or
just leave out the window if they don't
notice he's going in the house maybe
it's one of those things where if he
goes in the house the police are going
to come to the house for knocking on the
door but if he's stuck in a tree please
not going to climb up the tree although
the firefighters come up
and save a kitty
get the [ __ ] uh the city tree cutters
to just cut the truck
cut down an entire tree just because one
dude is trying to run away the
government has done crazy
uh yeah it's well [ __ ] yeah it's called
waco
hey hey it's full circle you and me but
that was texas wasn't it or oklahoma
that was texas yeah yeah they go they do
things a little different
shot a woman holding a baby yeah in the
head
that's some texas [ __ ] that wasn't waco
shooting a big uh woman that's ruby
ridge oh yeah ruben ridge thank you
river ridge good point why do i know
these things but i think they gasped no
did they get no they they burned they
threw in tear gas but the tear gas
ignited ignited the house and they were
everybody burned inside that was waco
yeah that's what you got yeah yeah yeah
was that the intention to throw into
your gas i mean it was not the intention
but they basically had they had a the
fire fight with the uh with the people
inside and then they tried to gas them
out but then the gas like caught [ __ ] on
fire and then they were like well
oops while we're [ __ ] up let's uh
let's let's go harder waco was supposed
to be like a coal right was that yeah
that's a branch dividends yeah that's
right then crash wait were they were
they picking off people that were
running out of the
the shelter i don't think they were like
i wouldn't be surprised if they do
though i think they're arresting people
that were running out but
the way that they attacked the shelter
yeah they did it like it was an army
exercise like it was bin laden well this
guy who hid in a tree yeah um the funny
part is that well at least i think it's
funny nypd's hostage negotiation unit
had been on scene for much of the 48
hours attempted to keep a dialogue and
convince the man to come down neighbors
say he also managed to get into the
house a few times via the window blah
blah blah sends to the same height but i
just imagine the idea of all the nypd's
hostage negotiations
i mean new york is like i i don't know
maybe i got the stereotype that new york
must see some wild [ __ ] yeah they're
probably busy as [ __ ] so i don't got
time to waste all this exactly but
you're still willing to wait for [ __ ]
two days and just for a 44 year old man
to get up they're paying overtime with
covet pay right now
so you haunt that that's nice
the reality of that is so disgusting or
it's like you just wait for him to come
down you're like he's not coming down
eventually but he just walks into the
window of his house [ __ ] this guy's done
this before this is pretty chill because
no one's at risk really i've been
watching a lot of survivor lately maybe
they're like hey
we got a spaghetti dinner right here
if you're if you come down now you can
just get in a running you think the
whole thing who was a who was who's the
sausage in this situation himself no the
the [ __ ] tree
they didn't want to cut down the tree
that was the hostages
have you seen a walnut shaker or almond
shaker so it's this [ __ ] it's like a
it's a it's a it's like a what do you
call it like a like a forklift right but
with that without that attachment it's
this [ __ ] thing that goes up and hugs
the tree and it shakes the [ __ ] out of
it
and it's like they say that it's like
being in an earthquake when you're
sitting on the truck and then it's
shaking the tree and then the tree looks
like it's being [ __ ] shaking like a
[ __ ] and all these seeds are
coming down right
that's what they should have used on
this thing like i was gonna die if
that's
the [ __ ] out of that that's like the
dark knight for trees dude
[Music]
you